what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so now that most of y'all young
kids are out of school or hopefully out
of school on your way to being at a
school probably finals week or something
along those lines we are going to go
back to your regularly scheduled
programming of alternating between
all-new all-different marvel and DC
rivers we are still going to do our
regular stuff of like Green Lantern on
Sundays and spider-man on Mondays until
we finish and that kind of thing and
then going into like Thor and all I kind
of get stuff but Monday through Friday
really like all every day of the week to
be honest we're going to alternate
Marvel and DC the only exception to that
it's for the next three weeks on the
weekends we're going to catch up with
Captain America but that will make sense
as we did a lead-up to secret Empire but
the fact remains here that at the moment
right now we are covering Nightwing how
his character must die essentially the
DC rebirth introduction of death being
really the new 52 even introduction of
death Lee here's a question would
anybody watch videos unlike the new 52
wanted Batman if I remaster that I'm
kind of curious I'm thinking about doing
that to get prepped for Batman metal
because I don't like the old videos but
I just kind of want to take people's
brains and sort of see what they think
anyway so the cool thing is that for
those of you guys who have been
following Nightwing over the course of
BC rebirth Shon sang was basically
introduced as a love interest of Dick
Grayson and it was really cool because
it's a way for him to kind of have his
own story his own continuity his own
thing you know basically fleshed out and
that's one of the things that feeling
was really focusing on when he wrote
Nightwing because it's one of the things
that he's always lacked Dick Grayson has
never had like his own archenemy he's
ever had like his own rogues gallery
he's ever had like a tried and true love
interest of his own it's always been
like facing off against Batman's foes or
it's always been facing off against some
villain of somebody else who just kind
of stumbled their way in to blüdhaven or
gotham or someone those lines or even
playing the role of Batman proper well
actually talk about that a little bit in
this particular story but the fact
remains here Shawn sang being in love
with the Grayson really works because
the prospect seems to exist that she may
be preggers now the cool thing about
this is that we actually switch over to
Damian Wayne this is one reasons why I
love Damian Wayne so much he's the
leader of the Teen Titans he's arrogant
he's full of hubris more so because of
the fact that everybody thinks that Dick
Grayson will be the one to take out
Batman instead of him and it's funny if
you guys are going through a reading
Twitter like well they call it trooper
or whatever it is but it's basically
Twitter but he's
through Twitter and he's just like why
doesn't anybody believe that I should be
Batman like everybody thinks it did
great says can be Batman and that's his
mission like his whole story like his
whole mission in the story is to prove
that he's the one that's going to take
out the mantle of Batman
instead of did Grayson and that's why I
love it so much is because he's like 13
and he's so arrogant like so haughty but
he's still just like a kid like who gets
upset over what they read on Twitter
it's just kind of funny to see that kind
of things affect a kid that way but the
fact remains here that speaking back out
with Dick Grayson again if there's
really not much going on here I mean
it's really him just kind of going
against the Bojack brothers you know
guys who run around with horse heads
it's kind of weird you know but then
Shaun basically calls much as hey look
I'm late I think I'm pregnant and so
again this is cool because what feel he
does is he focuses so much on Dick
Grayson where where Damian Wayne
disguise up and he was like hey look you
know I want to prove that I'm gonna be
the next Batman big Grayson does not
have time for any of that nonsense this
is one of those things we're usually
Dick Grayson would entertain the notion
he would kind of lead Damian on a little
bit oh yeah oh of course you'll be the
role of Batman No maybe I should be the
lineal kind of tease and you know um
just just give him a little bit of a
hard time but in this instance he states
to the prospect of being a dad now
what's so significant about this is it
hits home at everything that makes Dick
Grayson who he is because what he does
is he actually recollects on his time as
Batman and even looks at his time as
Nightwing and the one thing that
aggression is always harped on is the
idea that he's not Bruce Wayne that he's
not going to fall down the path of Bruce
Wayne he hasn't given up on romance he
hasn't given up on love he hasn't given
up on everything aside from being a
superhero he wants to get out and live
he wants to get out and enjoy his life
but a balancing act has to be maintained
between the fact that he's basically
protecting Bludhaven now and his life
was a father because rumor he just got
here so it's not like he's been in
Bludhaven for years and years and years
and years and now he has the opportunity
to leave it's basically like he just
showed up Sean say he might be pregnant
he's been here for weeks at best he
can't just run off and then just
basically leave Bludhaven unprotected it
would send a bad sign to the superhero
community as a whole and especially
towards the legacy of Batman to
basically say that you know what when
the time to get tough his sidekicks just
kind of bail out because they have other
things to do but all this really comes
to a head when he gets back home and he
basically ends up finding out that Sean
say he's been kid
now of course again this is kind of
crazy because what's left is this little
book you know something about Robin Hood
or you know something or other and
that's really it but what this does is
it basically leads directly into the
introduction of Deathwing now we will
get into a little bit of a discussion
not super in-depth because a 20-minute
video in and of itself but we will have
a discussion about the pre new 52 death
wing because that was an actual
character and he did have his own
stories and insecurities that I did not
expect to see in DC rebirth but the fact
remains here that this is cool because
what is up going on is is Damian Wayne
basically steals one of the Batmobile
shows up with Dick Grayson and says look
you know let's race off let's go find
what it is what's going on but it's also
Damian being a little bit honest and
letting his guard down now Damian never
does this right like it's it's rare it's
very very rare that he ever lets down
the mask of who he is
the mask of his you know haughtiness and
his arrogance and his refusal to admit
that he's wrong it's very very rare that
he ever lets that down and said nine
times out of 10 he's basically just kind
of like this is who I am this is what
I'm about come always right you know but
in this moment he basically says look
everything's changed like Duke is not
part of the equation he's just kind of
in a cave he's supposed to be something
different aside from a Robin Tim drugs
gone because remember they don't know
that he's been taken by mr. Oz as far as
Damian Wayne and Batman and Dick Grayson
and Barbara Gordon and all those guys
are aware Tim Drake is basically dead in
the eyes of Damian Wayne Jason Todd is
out doing his own thing with the outlaws
it's just Damian and Dick Grayson who
were the only people left carrying on
their original Mantle's
as part of the bat family and so because
of that Damian looks to Dick Grayson as
his last connection to the possibility
of what it means to carry on the Batman
mantle but to still be a Robin you know
it's almost like if you live in a live
in a town and you have friends that
you've known since elementary school and
then one group of friends moves to
Colorado and another group of friends
moves South Carolina another group of
friends supported over time eventually
the friends that you knew begin to kind
of dissipate and go away until they get
to the point where it's just you and as
sad as it is
that's where Damian Wayne feels right
now I mean Jason Todd is doing his own
thing Dukes doing his own thing Tim
Drake's gone it's just
Dick Grayson and Damian Wayne and so
because of that it really hits home at
the nature of who they are and of course
again don't have a little bit of a
discussion on that here in a second but
we actually switch over basically to
Deathwing himself now this looks starkly
different from the death lane that we're
used to
but it looks almost exactly like
Nightwing like his earlier outfit when
he first joined or first appeared in the
new 52
you know the whole age of the spiral
thing and all that kind of good stuff so
it's still kind of worked and it's still
sort of sort of intriguing but what this
does is it basically leads ed Grayson on
this kind of cat-and-mouse game which is
to say because of the fact that the King
Richard was a character in the Robin
Hood it leaves some you know basically
to an old to more or less worth the
memory of King Richard resides in the
sense of his body's not actually there
but it's just kind of a tomb but he ends
up finding a body inside of course the
body being being death laying the two of
them get into a conflict but it's kind
of cool because what happens here is
definitely basically begins to say
things like he is Dick Grayson he is
everything that Dick Grayson stands
where he believes himself to be dead you
know he believes himself to be Nightwing
you know basically making this case that
you are going to have to fall in order
to be ready for the coming conflict for
the coming dawn now this is an on
running trend in DC rebirth across the
board I mean everyone is doing this if
you're reading a button it's all men
this threats coming on the horizon if
you're reading Justice League this
threats coming on the horizon every
single title is doing this now we as the
reader would like to believe this is all
going to lead into like the DC Universe
versus like dr. Manhattan or like
Ozymandias or The Watchmen as a whole or
something along those lines we'd like to
believe that would be the case
I certainly hope it is but the fact your
name's here that we don't know off the
top of our heads but it's ominous is all
this is the idea seems to exist that
we're going to be seeing a lot of these
characters
returning to the ways they sort of used
to be to a degree and in fact we'll see
this a little bit with regards to Dick
Grayson but a funny thing is that the
way his character is depicted here is
the way the characters like him they
like him the way he is now because it's
such a throwback to the way he used to
be keep in mind Dick Grayson was like
this uncorruptible thing in the realm of
DC comics I mean that was one of the
major points that Jeff Jones made an
Infinite Crisis right I mean you had
this this world where superheroes have
become darker that's why superboy-prime
Alexander Luthor earth to Superman and
Lois Lane that's why they broke out of
the Paradise dimension and began the
process is sort of implementing their
own conquest and recreating the
multiverse in DC Comics because they
looked at superheroes as they existed
and said you guys are so much darker
than you used to be of course that was a
Geoff Johns meta commentary and
essentially saying the comic books in
the early 2000s really going in the
post-crisis Land
Cape are much darker than they should be
superheroes should be something to look
up to they shouldn't be a reflection of
real life of the grittiness in the
darkness of how life should be they
should be an escape and so because of
that despite all the changes that
happened with superheroes you know
Superman dying Batman having his back
broken Wonder Woman killing Maxwell Lord
despite all those major things that had
taken place Hal Jordan becoming parallax
so on and so forth it was really this
idea that through it all Dick Grayson
was this bright shining light of what a
tried and true superhero still
represents and so again because of that
that was more or less kind of rolled
over with DC rebirth his return to the
role of Nightwing taking up the mantle
of being the superhero being a protector
of Bludhaven it was returning him back
to his roots and I would go as far as to
say there's just kind of something
missing here but I would say that his
character as he's depicted here may be
slightly darker but not enough that it
makes a great big huge difference it he
kind of has to have this paradigm shift
now in his fight with death Wayne Dick
Grayson is actually slashed across the
forehead with a knife and what he
experiences is this massive shift he
experiences basically this vision of
like these infinite worlds we get the
original death wing we get Dick Grayson
when he was basically Talent we get all
these versions of his character over the
course of his entire publication history
different iterations of them whether
they be one-off say they'll come from
alternate realities whatever the case
may be and the question he asks is which
one of these is the real me am I the
alternate reality counterpart of another
one of these guys these guys see
themselves as legitimate do they see
themselves as a real Dick Grayson now
again this is also another ongoing theme
not to have any spoilers or anything but
the multiverse is one of the major plot
points of the button's storyline not
just in the contents of the most obvious
thing but in the contents of like
glimpses that we see over the course of
the over the course of really the second
issue and so because of that this whole
idea that the multiverse is basically
been affected the multiverse is being
brought in someone somewhere is doing
something to impact the multiverse in
its entirety is an on running theme and
DC Reber and that's one of the coolest
things and of course Seeley doesn't give
us a whole lot here he gives us kind of
a little taste he says hey guys like
look at the kind of things that are
coming down the pipe it's just enough to
whet our palate but it's also enough to
keep us coming back to keep us
interested and see what the story goes
now of course in the midst of there
we also end up having basically this
makeshift robinus this fake Robin
suddenly show up and jump into the fray
now Damian Wayne while he had been
trapped in a coffin more or less trapped
in a tomb began the process of kind of
beating his head against the other
against the opening in order to
basically get himself out and in the
process had the same vision as a its de
Grayson now what Seeley seems to be
saying here is that what's going on with
regard to the superheroes in terms of
how they view the world around them how
they view their universe is a matter of
perception dare I say it's an illusion
and even if it was only temporarily
Damian Wayne hitting its head against
the tomb Dick Grayson having its head
slash allowed them to basically see
beyond this illusion just long enough to
get a glimpse of all the different
variations of themselves that exist out
there in the multiverse and again it's a
really cool concept that's a really cool
idea to kind of hit home because what it
tells us is that we may end up seeing
shifts or we may end up seeing this kind
of Final Crisis esque scenario where
instead of just seeing Superman teaming
up with all the other supermen across
the multiverse we'll see all these
different multiversal iterations of
Batman and Nightwing and the flash and
Superman and Wonder Woman and you know
Green Lantern's so on and so forth all
these multiversal iterations of
themselves teaming up against some major
threat at this point it's all just
really speculation and I'm just kind of
throwing thoughts out there but the
possibility exists and that's what makes
these things so cool now for those
people who are seasoned with regards to
the Batman landscape just looking at
this version of Deathwing looking at
this version of Robin you probably know
right off the bat these are dollar
Tron's
and we'll find out what those are here
in a second but essentially this version
of Robin Otis this fake Damian as we'll
call him essentially takes out death
Lane and then tells you don't force Dick
Grayson and Damian Wayne hey here is
where Shawn is being held only for us to
find out that she's being held by
Professor Pig now what Seeley's doing
here is he's basically drawing into the
Grant Morrison era of Batman which is to
say a lot of these things like Simon
hurt like Professor Pig so on and so
forth what Professor pig was was
basically a crazy guy who would create
Dalek Ron's which is to say he would
basically take individuals he would put
them through all kinds of like mind
modification and like mind-altering
substances there were instances where at
least the illusion was that he would
forcefully modify the
bodies to where they were not a
particular gender he would basically
permanently attack faces to them but the
idea was once a person is taken by
Professor Pig and once they're
transformed into a dollar truant
there's no way to reverse the process
either you just let them live that way
or you just initiate a mercy killing
that's really all you can do I mean it's
one of those really interesting
scenarios in the realm of DC or there's
like a point of no return and I think
that DC does that a little more than
Marvel does and they might even do a
little bit better than Marvel doesn't
mean I think that each company kind of
has its own give and take for example
Marvel's cosmic landscape is far more
grandiose than DC's is but in terms of
like DC's nature of like sometimes you
just can't win sometimes there's no win
I think it's a little more visceral and
a little more tangible than it is with
Marvel Comics but the fact remains here
that you know to kind of go with this
give-and-take between the two companies
that's one of the things that DC has
really kind of running in their corner
is a sense that when when you know
professor Pig takes control of you
there's no coming back there's no way to
get away from that now there are some
people who are kind of able to jump back
and forth where the very least
understand or remember things but in
terms of them being the way they were
before that's gone and even then once
the process completely takes hold once
the process is 100% complete the person
they were before is gone forever and
that's really what Damien says you know
Damien basically says hey look that you
know this guy helped us it's fake Robin
helped us heal that's cool and
everything but he's a dollar tron all
right if we're going to give this guy
any measure of peace of mind the only
thing we can really do is kill him now
of course this leads directly into a
conflict between professor Pig and Dick
Grayson himself and of course you know
in the battle Damian in the Nightwing go
against these dollar Tron's and that's
really about it of course you also have
death Lee who's basically been held
captive and then ultimately kind of
beseeches and and speaks directly with
district Damian convinced you to take
Damian to release him after which death
lien basically kills them this is really
more kind of like a transition section
choose not a whole lot to go on here
it's really just kind of fighting and
that sort of thing but if dr. mains here
that what we end up dealing is once
professor Pig is essentially defeated
and once you basically have you know
definitely and kind of out there and
free again and you know Damian Wayne
initially going against him what
basically happens is Damian Wayne is
essentially kidnapped and professor Pig
makes the confession but it was never
him that he was that was the one running
the show it was somebody else who was
running the show
this other person was dr. Simon hurt now
dr. Simon hurt is basically a perfect
exercise in Grand Morrison running
around and teasing a zillion different
things and different writers have done
their own thing with dr. Simon hurt this
guy has been an ancestor of that man
that effectively set a whole bunch of
Batman's events in motion
some people speculate this guy's
Darkseid's some say he's the devil but
the idea here is that dr. Simon hurt is
inherently evil that guy is pure evil I
mean there's no goodness about him but
the idea of Simon hurt is that he had
constantly been obsessed with the notion
of Batman he'd constantly been obsessed
with the idea that the only reason why
Bruce Wayne became Batman the only
reason why he's able to be an effective
crime fighter is because of the fact
that he himself experienced massive
amounts of trauma and so in the eyes of
dr. Simon heard the only thing that
makes superheroes is trauma the only
thing that makes them better is
suffering and all kinds of different
issues and things like that now this is
why things are kind of interesting here
because under normal circumstances
Simon hurt exists to just make people's
lives miserable to make Batman's life
miserable anybody he comes across to
basically wreak havoc and cause all
kinds of different problems but that is
not necessarily the case it actually
seems like despite the fact that he's
got weird motivations despite the fact
that he's a little strange despite the
fact that he's basically a bad guy his
intentions actually seem to be somewhat
honourable here he's just going about it
all the wrong way the reason why I say
that is with Deathwing and Nightwing
basically fighting one another and kind
of going at it
we basically end up having Neil death
fleeing defeated by Nightwing after what
shawne's saying basically stays behind
to keep an eye on dessaline to kind of
keep him keep in captive but then we
have dig race into swimming down into
the bowels of where it is that Simon
Simon hurts located that during which
time he comes across all these dalla
Tron's of different versions of himself
where he's worn different costumes back
when he first appeared as bit Grayson
and DC Comics when he was Robin you know
when he first became night lane when he
was Batman all these different parts of
his life and what we end up having here
is Simon hurt basically saying that the
rule was that that Robin was going to
die at dawn and especially saying well
you know I got a little bit carried away
with the illusion being that he has
essentially killed killed Damian Winn
now the reason why I say this seems to
be something of an
nerville intention is because of the
fact that Dick Grayson is actually being
made to hallucinate Sula because of the
damage that he inflicted earlier when he
was hit with that knife but the fact
remains here did Simon hurt is doing
this to prepare Dick Grayson to
basically prepare him for the conflict
that's coming later on down the road now
we know this both because of what it is
that Simon Hurd says when he says
basically you're going to have to cast
aside the greatness of who you are and
become your darker self if you're going
to stand a chance of facing what's on
the horizon but at the same time we also
have Deathwing basically reiterating the
exact same thing to Shawn
Tseng essentially saying what's coming
later on down the road is going to be
dark it's going to be bad and these
superheroes are going to have to break
their rule or at least the Graysons is
gonna have to break his rule of not
killing if it means that he's going to
stand any chance of coming out on top
now the other half of this is that where
Dick Grayson is basically subjected to
all these illusions and the the Missal
prodding and so on by dr. Simon hurt the
tragedy is what makes superheroes this
is really silly kind of differentiating
at Dick Grayson and Batman with regards
to the Grayson basically saying that
unlike Bruce Wayne I am NOT defined by
my tragedy I'm defined by my actions now
this is 100% true I mean this is
definitive because remember did a
Grayson has played the role of Batman
Bruce Wayne has played the role of
Batman they both came from similar
circumstances the reason why their
parents died and how their parents died
are different in the sense that Joe
Chill basically killed Bruce Wayne's
parents and Dick Grayson's parents were
murdered you know and sabotage as
acrobats but the fact remains that both
of them lost their parents the
difference are the roads they took but
also because of the fact that there was
really no one to guide Bruce Wayne I
mean you had Alfred but Alfred wasn't a
superhero Alfred didn't have the same
experiences that Bruce Wayne did and so
because of that when Dick Grayson came
along having basically been the mirror
image of Bruce Wayne Bruce Wayne was
able to steer him away from his same
path
Dick Grayson was standing at a fork in
the road and Bruce Wayne said if you go
to the left you will be me if you go to
the right you will be your own person
Dick Grayson went to the right and he
became the hero that we know and love
today and so because of that he
basically says look I'm not defined by
the tragedies that I've experienced my
tragedies are a part of who I am the
other things that I've experienced the
things that I've done the things that
I've had done
things that I've seen done to the people
that I care about that's a part of who I
am but I'm not defined by it instead I
learn from it and there's a very huge
difference there
Batman's defined by his tragedy he is
Batman because of the death of his
parents we saw that when we went to the
whole Batman Green Lantern oven you know
we saw Hal Jordan basically come in to
terms with Batman after he had become
parallax and all that kind of stuff and
he gave that man a Green Lantern ring
and Batman created constructs out of his
parents house warden basically said hey
look use this to get past the death of
your parents and become a better man and
that man said no not yet there's so much
to do Batman does not let go of his
parents die it's the core reason his
motivation behind being Batman Dick
Grayson it's not the same way I know
this was a great big huge kind of you
know exposition and a great huge
explanation but I think it was a great
moment to really differentiate between
those two characters because I think
that with the events that are going to
be coming you know all the loss and all
the things that are going to happen the
deaths that are probably going to start
piling up you know the fact that all the
heroes are going to be pushed to the
brink you know and we may very well see
some heroes just don't make it out alive
I think it's important to kind of be
able to look back and talk about Dick
Grayson as a character so what we end up
doing is basically have you know Dick
Grayson overcoming Simon hurt only to
realize that Damian Wayne is in fact
still alive you know definitely
basically turns against Simon heard and
the two of them essentially stab each
other and it seems like you know they
both you know basically die in the
process and that really kind of wraps up
the story I mean there's really not a
whole lot going on here in terms of the
end result in terms of the of the whole
exposition comic book endings usually
wrap up pretty quick I mean they don't
draw out too much especially with
something like this just a five issue
series and so of course they basically
have Dick Grayson Shaun Singh heading
back home but Shaun is basically wrecked
by her whole situation by the whole
ordeal the idea of being kidnapped and
so on and so forth it's not anything she
couldn't handle but it definitely
changes how she views herself
because the memory of professor dick
looking at those Donald Ron's and seeing
what she could have been certainly
changed her in a lot of ways not only
that it of course turns out that she's
not actually pregnant but in the end we
had this great conversation between
Damian and and Nightwing and Damian
Wayne basically says look the truth
about his whole obsession with Nightwing
becoming Batman is that he feels like he
would have basically lost big races like
Dick Grayson would have just gone away
Dick Grayson what it basically just left
you know there would be no room for for
Damian Wayne more
so than that when Damien learned that
Dick Grayson was going to have a son
that he almost felt like Damien would be
replaced and that's one of the most
interesting things here it's because
what it shows us is that despite all his
bravado in all his pomp and circumstance
at all this mountain at the end of the
day Damian Wayne wants to be needed and
then some people are people want to be
needed people want to know that somebody
out there needs them they they have a
desire for that person and Damian Wayne
is the exact same way and it's
beautifully done because it makes them
human it takes this kid who would
otherwise seem like a soldier this kid
that is deadly and every sense of the
word you know and it makes him real it
makes him tangible it makes it human and
that's one of the coolest things about
this that's why I love this so much is
because it just works so we kind of get
this little segment this little bit
where Dick Grayson basically says look
Damian you are irreplaceable I was the
son of Bruce Wayne for years and years
and years because he didn't know you
were there because you hadn't been born
yet whatever the case may have been I
was the closest thing Bruce Wayne had to
his son but no matter what anybody tells
you come what may
no matter what happens you will always
be the biological son of Bruce Wayne you
will always be that guy that is the
nature of who you are and no one can
take that away from you so again it's
really kind of this inspiring nature of
Nightwing in relation to the various
superheroes around him and that's one of
the coolest things is he always inspires
people to become better than where they
currently are but in any event if you
guys are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys with the sub button
to become part of the Rob core if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah I will catch you
guys later
[Music]